oh let's roll d4 Knight f6 and e6 we are
entering what we are entering the
territory known as nims Oh Indian land
or BOGO Indian depending on how white
responds Knight c3 Bishop b4 is the NIMS
Oh Indian if Knight f3 and b6 or excuse
me if Knight f3 and Bishop here that
would be the bogo the bow go okay i
played this earlier Queen c2 and I was
suggesting b6 is that correct but I
giving bad suggestions when I said that
I want to try something else we're let's
see five to try c5 hmm that is a weak
point now is it not is there a drawback
to the Queen see to move is there a
weakness that's been created now okay
take here is the Queen going to
recapture ah ok where do I want my puns
million-dollar question where do I want
my pawns quickly in the twitch chat
hopefully the majority of you who are
tuned in for many of the streams will
know this answer throw a question that
Bishop see what it wants to do
let's get this in what's the
million-dollar question the answer to it
i mean i already rattled off the
million-dollar question ponds on dark
since I with my remaining bishop it
sunlight I want to keep them coordinated
these guys say all right I got the dark
squares don't worry about it my bishop
says okay I got the light squares you
don't worry about them got it it's good
night here hang on on here no I'm
dropping a pot if I do that okay let's
come here now pond push I wonder I
really need to be cautious of night here
because if d5 night to this square then
Bishop takes Knight cannot be met with
Queen recapture because of Queen a4 and
goodbye to my night but I have the time
now to get that move in and i think i'm
going to run with b6 my night is
unprotected because of this last move
maybe there was an opportunity to
actually take and play Queen here I
might have just slipped up right there
what about that still might be available
this is bothering me okay um it's not
really what I want to do I'm gonna play
here though fish up here yeah that seems
right Bishop here and then the plan is
going to be to eventually play here let
me do this first support this pond
supporting my central points my queen is
in some sense coordinated with my pawns
right she's supporting you know II five
in particular I might want to also run
with g 5 which is mmm a bit committal
right because if I'm going to be
castling in this direction there's weak
points without a doubt f5 h5 f 6 h-6
with just one pond
of there's four squares that become
holes serious weaknesses the f5 square
being the one that's the one that I
think and maybe be exploited easiest and
now i'm cringing a bit here do I want to
put pressure that now I can't really do
that I'm gonna try this and then and
then I'm push this is tough this is very
tough right here my night is well hon
push there's going to be F I want to
prevent f4 takes and then a pin in this
direction so i don't i don't want to
deal with that I and there might be
actually night here and then this a pond
could run down here and the this side of
the board can open up so I'm doing this
to reinforce eating the eve or or e 5
and also get out of potential pins here
now this could become a serious problem
quickly I think I really do need to cast
a queen side and you know there's
nothing really I could do in response to
night here I have to take and now that
move I don't understand hmm wait a
second now I'm going to come back over
in this direction now that f4 can't now
I don't need the support on this square
I want to get to this square in the
meantime Bishop there is a nice idea I
better play here there might have been a
queen check and i would have to block
maybe Queen check first and then I'd
have to block my queen or something
we're pretty tight here with the time
night on f4 i think is going to be
pretty good let's see about that I can't
well so much for castling um night here
the queen is running a bit out of
squares but whoa a queen trade
this can't be right because now this is
starting to really show itself Bishop
there but now after i take i play this
and this is a potential target maybe or
even this so i have a grip on the
position there aren't any successful
pawn breaks for black there is rook c8
to this square and there's something
better what about getting some more
space here there's no way that this pond
could fall actually I'm going to do this
and get some more King position in where
can I go with my king rook be4 just met
with rook c8 and where do I make
progress hmm might be pretty tricky here
I might have to get this FF pun involved
okay can my night do something else ah
yes I want to get them here but I don't
want to go here because the bishop will
take him out so boom boom boom boom
let's go let's do it closed position and
if King here in a hat needs to come
quickly okay my pone is taking that into
account very good let me do something
else maybe seeing how it's going to be
snipped as soon as that move comes about
because otherwise night here if Knight
takes I play here i'm on the brook and
this night although there might be still
something there let me let me double up
rooks first I don't think there's any
hurry and actually let okay let me do
this before I double rooks I better move
a bit quicker i'm gonna get my king in a
better spot so what is the plan here oh
oh wait a second i changed my mind i
forgot about that pun my opponent is
maneuvering very well okay I'm coming in
for the kill I think
it's gonna be taken I'm going to
actually I'm gonna tow this is a mistake
because I get the the file now I get
activity for my rugs 30 seconds though
to figure it out I'm on the bishop in
the pond I get this guy it's the plan I
want to get my night to g3 next g3 I
don't have to go after that a pond g3
can I get it to g3 i'm close to getting
there actually by way of f1 oh this
could be brutal Oh bishop in no i have a
check a fork check there in a knot my
opponent in and not right now the rook
has to move I want to get my king over
we're actually my rook is in a good spot
I want to play f5 f5 is the next pond
break oh I had a fork go back there I
have a fork oh that was missed time
pressure and now it's gonna be just
watch out for Steelman actually let me
let me target this I want to get them
out of stalemate back over here no time
the rook is cutting them off and I think
it's smooth sailing from here and then
pawn push next right down to the wire Oh
time scramble territory good game very
nice oh man very very good game let's go
back through this one let's see how
either one of us could have improved
upon things my opponent is saying right
idea wrong square for the rook at the
end yeah you have to shuffle back and
forth like that I think there might have
been a win somehow with like there's
still an f5 break or maybe an a6 break
i'm not sure but let's let's have a look
at it so we're working with this
structure
and what moves caught me off guard I
wonder about this one actually as soon
as i played b 6i think there's a shot
with Bishop takes Queen takes Queen
efore this pond is hit three times in my
night is hit actually there's nothing
that I just defend with the Bishop e7
false alarm okay so pressure on c4 and
this right here struck me is off I think
you play f4 here open this position up
and what I was really fearing is
something like the rooks springing to
life on this F file I think f5 and I'm
there's no way I could be better this is
collapsing you could play F for you
could double the rooks on the F file you
could play Bishop to h5 there's problems
very serious problems over here and in
the meantime I think it's a bit
convenient for you to be defending
against my night and it's pressure on
your c4 pond he's just kind of viewing
this night as being out of play it's
really turn into a strategic game as
soon as what a difference upon move
makes efore says okay you know what I
could come over here and get on f4 but
f-for means I really have to sit and
hope for the best and I'm seeing a lot
of pressure being placed on this
diagonal or this one as was played in
the game but it's much more easy to deal
with the bishop being on this diagonal
if the if the position is closed if
these files are not opened up so I don't
think it turns out to be quite enough I
think I'm in serious trouble if f4 is
played instead of e four so and the
Queen exchange I don't know if I was
really too afraid of that this gets this
gets tough I don't want to allow this
pond push I was I was thinking about d3
at that point my opponent was saying
that they thought they could get a
Knight to f5 I think eventually it could
have in this later game just in the nick
of time my opponent is definitely in
this isn't I'm pressure as well this is
a strong
on playing the King move a lot of
getting ready to sniff the night as soon
as it plays here right now the night
could get to that square right here and
I totally forgot about that I'm kind of
going back and forth of my king back the
bishop up and then get to this square
and then here and then that's a that's a
problem although for the one moment you
play your night to this square maybe I
could be playing to this square and then
this one and be a bit disruptive
interesting game without a doubt the
mistakes the main what mistakes are ones
that came about in time pressure
allowing me to get my night to this
square I don't know really what I have
if Bishop takes Knight is played Bishop
takes Knight rook takes all right what
do I have the only pawn break that i
think would maybe be some improvement is
f5 and then g4 or something like if I
have my rook on this point putting
pressure on d5 maybe f5 some f4 push but
I think it should be able to hold for
white very good game very nice go gamba
dear gambit ear okay let's see my
opponent is typing something else they
want to share something else about the
game saying I knew I should have taken
the night on c5 but when it was there
just a mental lapse okay yeah so they
had the right idea I mean I I assumed
you knew that it was that it was the
case because that's why the King h1
Bishop g1 moves were played so he can
get in a position just in the nick of
time to do that so yeah it was just a
mental lapse it's easy to do in these
faster games okay